สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไร
คะ
วันนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะ
ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 3
เดือนอะไรคะ
กันยายน
ผู้หญิงลากไม่ไปนะคะนักเรียน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันศุกร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 2
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนกันยายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันจันทร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 4 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนกันยายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ค่ะปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลาบ่าย 2
โมง
บ่ายสองโมง
กี่นาที
3 นาทีค่ะ
ค่ะ
นักเรียน
14:00 นเป็นเวลาที่ออสเตรเลีย
ใช่เวลาที่ออสเตรเลียค่ะใช่ค่ะแต่ครูหญิง
เนี่ยอยู่ประเทศไทยค่ะประเทศไทยเนี่ย 11
โมง
3 นาที
11 โมง 3 นาที
สายครูฟ้าเวลาของครูฟ้าเร็วกว่าเวลาของ
ครูหญิงนะคะเร็วกว่ามากเลย
เร็วกว่า 3 ชั่วโมง
ใช่ 3 ชั่วโมงใช่ไหมคะตอนครูฟ้าเนี่ยตอน
นี้นะตอนนี้นะคะ
แต่เมื่อก่อน
ครูฟ้าอยู่ประเทศไทยใช่ไหมคะ
นักเรียน
[เพลง]
ตอนครูฟ้าอยู่ประเทศไทยเนี่ย
ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
อยู่ที่บ้าน
ใช่ไหมคะ
อยู่ที่บ้านครูฟ้าครูหญิงจำได้ครูฟ้าครู
ฟ้าเนาะแล้วก็มีคุณพ่อมีคุณแม่ใช่ไหมที่
บ้านที่ครูอยู่เนี่ยมีครูฟ้ามีคุณแม่มี
คุณนะมีคุณป้ามีคน
คน
ใช่ไหมอยู่หลายๆคนครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่อยู่คน
เดียวแต่ตอนนี้
ครูฟ้าอยู่ออสเตรเลีย
ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
อยู่ที่บ้าน
ครูฟ้า
คนเดียวอยู่คนเดียว
หรือว่า
อยู่หลายๆคนนะคะ
ลูกฟ้าอยู่ออสเตรเลียเนี่ยนะคะครูฟ้าอยู่
ที่บ้าน
อยู่คนเดียวไหม
หลายๆคน
อยู่หลายๆคนอยู่กันกี่คนคะ
อยู่กัน
ฟ้าคิดก่อนนะคะ
6 คนค่ะ
เยอะนะ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยชอบอยู่หลายๆคนหรือว่าชอบอยู่
คนเดียว
เอหรือว่า
BA เนี่ยอยู่คนเดียว
บีเนี่ยอยู่หลายๆคน
ครูฟ้าก็เคยอยู่คนเดียวใช่ไหมเมื่อก่อน
ให้ครูฟ้าเคยอยู่คนเดียวนะคะ
เป็นคนที่ชอบอยู่คนเดียว
แต่ว่า
ชอบอยู่คนเดียวและชอบอยู่
หลายๆคนด้วย
ใช่ไหม
ชอบอยู่คนเดียวด้วยชอบอยู่หลายๆคนด้วย
คุณเข้าใจนะคะเพราะว่าบางครั้งเนี่ยบาง
อย่างเราเนี่ยชอบคนเดียวชอบอยู่คนเดียว
ชอบทำคนเดียวแต่บางอย่างเนี่ยถ้าทำคน
เดียว
มันบางทีมันแบบไม่สนุก
หลายๆคนเนี่ยสนุกมากกว่าใช่ไหมคะ
ก็เลยเข้าใจว่าครูฟ้าแบบอยู่คนเดียวครู
ฟ้าก็ชอบอยู่หลายๆคนครูฟ้าก็ชอบแต่วันนี้
เนี่ยเราไม่เอาเรื่องที่เราชอบแบบอยู่
หลายๆคนเราอยากคุยกันเรื่องอยู่คนเดียวทำ
อะไรคนเดียวอาจจะไม่ได้อยู่คนเดียวก็ได้
ครูหญิงเนี่ยนะผู้หญิงอยู่กรุงเทพฯนะ
กรุงเทพฯ
อยู่คอนโดมิเนียมใช่ไหมคะ
ผู้หญิงเนี่ย
อยู่คนเดียวหมายถึงในห้องผู้หญิงนะไม่ใช่
ทางคอนโดมิเนียมนะคะในห้องเนี่ยครูหญิง
เนี่ยอยู่คนเดียวใช่ไหม
ก็โอเค
แต่ว่าผู้หญิงชอบ
ก็ชอบค่ะครูฟ้าชอบชอบอยู่คนเดียวพออยู่คน
เดียวเนี่ย
ทุกวันทุกวันวันจันทร์
จนถึงวันอาทิตย์ใช่ไหมคะ
ทุกวันทุกวันทุกวันทุกวันเนี่ยก็กินข้าว
คนเดียว
อยู่คนเดียวนักเรียนกินแฮมเบอร์เกอร์ให้
ผู้หญิงเหรอคะ
ผู้หญิงทำไมคุณหญิงเหมือนผู้ชายคะ
ผู้หญิงผมผมไม่ใช่สีดำอันนี้การ์ตูนให้ดู
เฉยๆค่ะว่ารูปนี้เนี่ยคือรูปกินข้าวก็ครู
หญิงอยู่คนเดียวก็ต้องกินข้าวคนเดียว
บางครั้งผู้หญิงก็ไม่ได้ชอบกินข้าวคน
เดียวนะครูฟ้า
ผู้หญิงไม่ชอบกินข้าวคนเดียวใช่ไหมทำไม
นี่เอ้ากินข้าวคนเดียวเนี่ย
ไม่ได้คุยกับใครถ้าครูหญิงกินข้าวกับครู
ฟ้านี้ครูหญิงใช่ไหมแล้วก็มีครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ก็คุยกันแล้วก็ Order อาหารอาหารอาหาร
เยอะๆได้ไง
ไม่รู้ว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยครูฟ้าชอบกินข้าวคน
เดียวไหม
ครูฟ้าชอบกินข้าวคนเดียวนะคะ
คิดว่ากินข้าวคนเดียวโอเค
คือฟ้าก็ชอบ
กินข้าวคนเดียวและครูฟ้าก็ชอบกินข้าวกับ
เพื่อน
กับหลายๆคนครูบาก็โอเค
แต่ว่ากินข้าวคนเดียวเนี่ยมันโอเคนะหมาย
ถึง
กินข้าวคนเดียวในบ้านใช่ไหม
กินข้าวคนเดียวในบ้านฟ้าก็โอเคหรือจะไป
ไปข้างนอกบ้าน
ร้านอาหาร
ไปร้านอาหาร
ครูฟ้านะคะ
ไปร้านอาหารกินข้าวคนเดียว
ฟ้าก็โอเค
ก็ชอบก็เป็นอะไรที่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยชอบทำคน
เดียวหรือว่าคนเดียวได้อ่ะเนอะกินข้าว
ก่อนใช่มันก็
วันนี้ครูฟ้าอาจจะชอบกินข้าวคนเดียว
พรุ่งนี้ครูฟ้าอาจจะชอบกินข้าวกับเพื่อน
มันก็แล้วแต่นะคะนักเรียนแล้วแต่ก็ชอบก็
ได้ใช่ไหมคะโอเคกินข้าวคนเดียวโอเค
กินข้าวคนเดียวโอเคประเทศไทยเนี่ยนะคะจะ
มีอาหารที่เรียกว่าหมูกระทะที่นักเรียน
เห็นในรูปนี้เนี่ยนะคะคือหมูกระทะมันเป็น
บาร์บีคิวแบบคนไทยหมูกระทะที่ประเทศไทย
เนี่ยคิดว่าประมาณ 90% แล้วกันเนาะไม่ใช่
ร้อยเปอร์เซ็นต์ 90% เนี่ยเป็นบุฟเฟ่ต์
บุฟเฟ่ต์
ประมาณเท่าไหร่ 90 นาทีไหม
มีเวลากินนะคะ 90 นาทีกินเท่าไหร่ก็ได้
กินเยอะๆโอเคอันนี้คือบุฟเฟ่ต์หมูกระทะ
ที่ประเทศไทยเวลาที่ไปกินกระทะกิน
บุฟเฟ่ต์ที่ประเทศไทยเนี่ยครูฟ้าไปกินคน
เดียว
โอเคไหมชอบไหม
มาคิดว่าถ้าไปกินหมูกะทะ
คู่ฟ้ากินอยู่คนเดียวไม่โอเคค่ะ
เพราะว่าคุณฟ้า
สมมุติ
มีผัก
มีผักมีผัก
100% ใช่ไหม
ครูฟ้าอาจจะกิน
ประมาณ
45%
ครูฟ้ากินนิดหน่อยนะคะ
มันไม่โอเคนะหมูกระทะ
399 บาท
กินไป
จ่ายเงิน 300 บาท
กิน 120 ผู้หญิงก็คิดว่าถ้าบางคนเนี่ยชอบ
กินข้าวคนเดียวชอบกินข้าวคนเดียวกินอาหาร
คนเดียวแต่ถ้าไปกินหมูกระทะกินบุฟเฟต์กิน
คนเดียวเนี่ยมันไม่สนุกมีครูหญิงครูฟ้า
แล้วก็มีคนคนเยอะๆใช่ไหมมีเนี่ยมีคนคน
ผู้ชายผู้หญิงหลายๆคนเนี่ยกินหมูกระทะ
ด้วยกันหลายๆคนทุกคนเนี่ยช่วยกันปิ้งช่วย
กันปิ้งหมูกระทะมันสนุกมากกว่าเนอะ
ไม่น่าหรือว่าบุฟเฟ่ต์นะคะน่าจะเป็นสิ่ง
คนไทยหลายๆคนเนี่ยไม่ชอบทำคนเดียวแล้วก็
คิดว่า
อันหมูกระทะไม่ให้กินคนเดียวนะคะ
ถ้าครูหญิงเนี่ยไปร้านหมูกะทะแล้วก็บอก
ว่าคนเดียวเขาก็จะบอกไม่ได้ใช่ไหมไม่ได้
ไม่ได้
2 คนมากกว่า 1 คนก็คือ 2 คน 3 คนโอเค
อะไรอย่างนี้ 1 คนโอเค
คิดว่าผู้หญิงก็คิดอย่างนั้นเหมือนกันนะ
ร้านบุฟเฟ่ต์ส่วนใหญ่ 1 คนไม่ได้อยู่แล้ว
นะคะแต่ว่ามีอีกอย่างนึงนะคะก็คือดูหนัง
บางคนเนี่ยดูหนังคนเดียวไม่ได้นะ
ผู้หญิงโอเคนะครูหญิงชอบดูหนังคนเดียวครู
ฟ้าครูฟ้าชอบดูหนังคนเดียวไหม
เคยดูหนังคนเดียวนะคะ
จริงหรอ
ความไม่เคย
ดูหนังคนเดียว
อ๋อแปลว่าทุกครั้งที่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยไปดูหนัง
ก็จะมีครูฟ้าแล้วก็มีเพื่อนใช่ไหมเพื่อนๆ
อันนี้อันนี้คนนี้ครูฟ้านะคะก็จะมีเพื่อน
มีเพื่อนไปดูด้วย
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยเคยดูหนังคนเดียวโอเคนะจริง
หรอผู้หญิงชอบหรอคะ
ชอบนะคะดูหนังคนเดียวคือครูหญิงไปดูหนัง
กับครูฟ้าครูหญิงก็ชอบผู้หญิงดูหนังคน
เดียวครูหญิงก็ชอบก็คือ 2 อย่างเนี่ยโอเค
ดูคนเดียว
ดูกับเพื่อนก็ได้แต่บางคนเนี่ยชอบดูหนัง
คนเดียวก็มีนะไม่ชอบไปดูกับเพื่อน
คิดว่าดูหนังมันมืดไง
ก็เลยเข้าใจไหมนี่นะคะ
โรงหนังค่ะ
พอเราไปดูหนังเขาก็จะปิดไฟ
อ๋อมันก็จะมืดใช่ไหมคะ
โอเคงั้นครูฟ้าเนี่ยน่าจะเป็นอย่างแรกนะ
ที่ครูฟ้าไม่ชอบทำคนเดียว
มันมืด
ไปกับเพื่อนโอเค
เข้าใจค่ะเพราะว่าอย่างดูหนังเนี่ยครู
หญิงดูหนังคนเดียวก็ชอบดูหนังหลายๆคนก็
ชอบนะคะแต่จะมีอีกอย่างนึงที่ครูหญิง
เนี่ยชอบทำคนเดียวไม่ชอบไปหลายๆคนชอบไปทำ
คนเดียวเลย
อะไร
ท็อปปิ้งค่ะครูฟ้า
ผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงชอบไปช็อปปิ้งคนเดียวหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะการไปช้อปปิ้งไปซื้อของเนี่ยนะคะ
ครูหญิงน่ะชอบ
ไปทำคนเดียวชอบช้อปปิ้งคนเดียว
ทำไม
ครูหญิงเป็นคนที่ชอบช้อปปิ้งแล้วก็เดินดู
คนเดียวถ้าครูหญิงไปกับครูฟ้าอย่างนี้
ผู้หญิงก็คิดครูฟ้าโอเคไหมครูฟ้ารอรอครู
หญิงซื้อของซื้อเสื้อซื้ออาหารก็เหมือน
กันนะไปช้อปปิ้งที่ซุปเปอร์มาเก็ตผู้หญิง
ก็ชอบคนเดียว
รู้สึกว่าเดินคนเดียวใช้เวลานานๆ
โอเคถ้าครูหญิงไปกับฟ้าไง
ผู้หญิง
ภูฟ้าอย่างนี้ผู้หญิงเดิน
ช็อปปิ้งสมมุติคุณหญิงชอปปิ้งเสื้อผู้
หญิงก็คิดเองครูฟ้าชอบซื้อเสื้อไหมครูฟ้า
โอเคไหมไงก็เลยคิดเดินคนเดียวดีกว่าผู้
หญิงชอบช้อปปิ้งคนเดียวมากเป็นอย่างนึง
ที่ผู้หญิงชอบทำคนเดียวไม่ชอบไปกับเพื่อน
แต่ผู้หญิงไปท็อปปิ้งกับครูฟ้าได้นะแต่
ผู้หญิงจะไม่ซื้อถ้าคุณหญิงอยากซื้อผู้
หญิงไปคนเดียวทำไม
ไม่รู้เหมือนกัน
ชอบอ่ะรู้สึกอยากเดินเข้าดูๆๆ
ดูคนเดียวช้อปปิ้งคนเดียวผู้หญิงเนี่ยมี
ความสุขมากๆค่ะครูฟ้าครูฟ้าชอบช้อปปิ้งคน
เดียวไหม
ชอบทำคนเดียวไหมคะช้อปปิ้ง
คนเดียวครูฟ้าก็โอเคชอบปิ้งกับพืชกับคน
อื่นๆกับครูหญิงชอปปิ้ง
หลายๆคนอุปาก็โอเค
ว่าเคยไปช้อปปิ้งคนเดียวบ่อยๆ
เออใช่แต่ครูฟ้าก็ไปช้อปปิ้งกับเพื่อนได้
ใช่ไปกับเพื่อนได้
คือครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ชอบอยู่คนเดียวนะนักเรียนชอบอยู่คนเดียว
แต่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยก็ชอบอยู่กับเพื่อนด้วยไง
ส่วนใหญ่ครูฟ้าออกไปช้อปปิ้งไปกินข้าวไป
ดูหนังเราต้องไปกับเพื่อนนะคะจะไปกับ
เพื่อนก็เลยครูฟ้าอยู่กับเพื่อนมากๆอ่ะก็
เลยโอเคแล้ว
แล้วมีอะไรไหมคะที่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยชอบทำคน
เดียวที่แบบถ้าหลายๆคนอยู่ครูฟ้าจะรู้สึก
อาจจะไม่สนุกเป็นสิ่งที่ครูฟ้าชอบทำคน
เดียวมีไหมผู้หญิงน่ะชอบช้อปปิ้งคนเดียว
นะ
มีความสุข
เล่นเกมคนเดียวค่ะ
หมายถึงที่บ้านใช่ไหมที่ในห้องเดียวกัน
ใช่ไหมคะ
อืม
เข้าใจมั้ยสมมติคอมพิวเตอร์นะ
ก็
คีย์บอร์ด
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยจะชอบเล่นเกม
คนเดียว
ต้องอยู่ในห้องเกมคอมพิวเตอร์ใช่ไหมครู
ฟ้าใช่เกมคอมพิวเตอร์เนี่ยแหละ
ชอบนั่งอยู่คนเดียวนะ
ครูหญิงอยู่ในห้องครูฟ้านั่งเล่นเกมด้วย
กันครูฟ้าจะรู้สึก
ไม่ค่อยโอเคใช่ไหมชอบทำคนเดียวมากกว่า
ก็โอเคถ้าคุณหญิงมาเคาะนกๆๆแล้วผู้หญิง
อยากอยู่กับกูฟ้าโอเคแต่ว่าไม่ชอบอยู่คน
เดียว
ครูฟ้าคนเดียวนะคะ
โอเค
แล้วก็ครูฟ้าชอบ
ไปร้านหนังสือคนเดียว
เวลาครูฟ้าคิดอยากจะซื้อพวกหนังสือ
ครูฟ้าก็ต้องไปร้านหนังสือ
ครูฟ้าอาจจะไม่ชอบชอปปิ้งคนเดียวแต่ถ้าไป
ร้านหนังสือชอบเดินดูคนเดียวหรอคะ
ชอบไปร้านหนังสือคนเดียวทำไมอ่ะคะครูฟ้า
เพราะว่าเวลาครูฟ้าอ่านหนังสือคือว่าจะ
ต้องโฟกัสไง
ครูหญิงอยู่ด้วยครูฟ้าจะโฟกัสที่หนังสือ
100% ไม่ได้หรอถ้าผู้หญิงไม่ได้ครูฟ้า
โฟกัส 100% ไม่ได้
ครูฟ้าก็เลยชอบไปร้านหนังสือคนเดียวอะไร
คะใช่ร้านหนังสือคนเดียวค่ะ
ก็คิดซื้อไม่ซื้อมันต้องคิด
ว่าซื้อหนังสือนี้หรือซื้อหนังสือเล่มนี้
ซื้อหนังสือเล่มนี้หรือหนังสือเล่มนี้
ใช่ไหมคะเขาก็ชอบไปแบบเขาเรียกอะไรอ่ะ
แคมป์ปิ้งหรอที่มันจะมีเต็นท์อย่างนี้อัน
นี้เป็นเต็นท์นะนักเรียนเข้าใจเป็นเต็นท์
ไหมแล้วมันจะมีแบบ
ผู้หญิงก็วาดไม่ถูกอ่ะค่ะเป็นแคมป์ปิ้ง
อ่ะแล้วก็มีแบบต้นไม้อย่างนี้ค่ะแล้วก็จะ
มีเก้าอี้ใช่ไหมเก้าอี้แล้วก็นั่ง
เต็นท์เนี่ยบางคนชอบไปแคมป์ปิ้งคนเดียวนะ
เห็นมีผู้หญิงคนแบบ
ใน YouTube นะคะนักเรียนแต่เขาไม่ใช่คน
ไทยนะผู้หญิงก็ฟังภาษาเกาหลีไม่เข้าใจนะ
แต่ชอบดูเขาไปกันปิ้งคนเดียวทำอาหารคน
เดียว
ไปคนเดียวดีกว่าใช่ไหมบางอย่างใช่ก็ไม่
รู้เหมือนกันนะคะว่ามีอะไรที่นักเรียน
เนี่ยชอบทำคนเดียว
ครูฟ้าชอบขึ้นรถบัสคนเดียวค่ะ
รถบัสแบบว่า
รถบัสแบบของ
ประเทศไทยมันคือรถเมล์
ก็ขึ้นรถบัสกูมาชอบกูคนเดียว
คิดว่าไม่ชอบเดินทางชอบเดินทางคนเดียวมาก
กว่าคือคุณบาสรถไฟ
รถไฟใช่ไหม
หรือว่าเครื่องบินอะไรก็ได้ที่เป็นการแบบ
เดินทางอ่ะคิดว่าครูฟ้าชอบคนเดียวเพราะ
ชอบ
จะฟังเพลงใช่ไหมว่าจะอ่านหนังสือเพราะไม่
ชอบคุย
คือ
เวลาเดินทางค่ะเวลาเดินทางใช่คือไม่ชอบ
คุยอ่ะเวลาครูฟ้ามีเพื่อนเพื่อนก็จะพูดๆๆ
คุยๆอย่างเงี้ยก็ไม่ชอบนะ
ชอบขึ้นรถใช่มั้ยอาจารย์
ขับรถได้ครูฟ้าน่าจะชอบขับรถคนเดียวไม่
ใช่มีเพื่อนเพื่อนนั่งด้วยว่าจะได้ฟัง
เพลงทำอะไรคนเดียว
นั่นแหละคือสิ่งที่ครูฟ้าชอบทำคนเดียวนะ
คะก็ไม่รู้เหมือนกันว่ามีอะไรที่นักเรียน
ชอบทำคนเดียวก็ comment คุยกับเราได้นะคะ
ส่วนวีดีโอนี้ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าไปก่อนเนาะ
แล้วเดี๋ยวเราเจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้านะคะ
นักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะ